[Musique]
je vous parlais tout ce que vous voulez
les gares les styles jour là mon frère
on va tous à la cour c'est sûr c'est pas
possible je te crois pas je suis sûr
qu'il est plus rapide car est il est
trop petit ok emparé 5 $ alors trop bien
joué mais roman qu'est ce que je vous
avais dit c'est ouais tu racontes parano
non il a triché watts a envoyé à
l'abonné maintenant
maintenant
maman qu'est ce qu'il n'a pas pas bon
baba
[Musique]
allez vous faites encore de retour et
c'est bon
vous aviez dit quatre tours ça sera 6 tu
veux en faire huit alors jack sommes
encore en train de te plaint toujours la
même rengaine avec toi le grenat
tu veux en faire 12 ouais on en fait 12
mai on va perdre whitehall hockey
c'est toi qui va perdre mais bon t'as
l'habitude comme ton frère tu as dit
quoi et qu'est-ce qui a rien à [ __ ]
faites les vous mêmes je veux plus te
voir ici on va laisser le parti le coach
des mauvaises façons
et et du doubs fait pas gaffe à eric
revient allez va bien
[Musique]
c'est fini j'arrête
oui
allez vas-y dis moi ce que j'ai raté
comme d'habitude mon école fait des
trois grandes foulées il sert pas de ses
orteils et sept filles et le cours sur
les talons et déjà comme c'est une
laisse partir comme ça allait aller à
couches
qu'est ce que tu attends bien attendre
ap ap
we all et belle allée ouais je lis
voisine
attends attends à la vache les trophées
c'est bon ça laisse un rôle mais bien
joué
drew
il faudrait que tu ailles voir ali de ma
part demain pourquoi tu vas pas tout
cela
tu sais très bien tu en liberté
conditionnelle
je peux pas faire ça à temps des
salaires de maman couvre pas l'emprunt
va falloir que tu fasse des efforts
maintenant
et puis là je n'ai pas envie de le voir
et t'as pas de quoi payer c'est ça tu
sais quoi cette bouffe c'est immonde à
je peux pas à vache c'est immangeable
ça va me nages
tu devrais être couché
yahoo
non
[Musique]
que nous
oh
allez faut que thierry maintenant tu
sais bien que c'est pas possible j'ai
déjà essayé on n'est pas assez souple
allez la ballerine évasée
elie un sac pour toi d'accord qu'est-ce
que je dois dire pour l'argent dis-lui
juste que je peux pas venir aujourd'hui
et rennes pas trop j'ai encore besoin de
toi après
[Musique]
les
et
[Musique]
où
sa lutte chimique je dois voir l
flash encore toi ça va avec ça devient
une habitude
ça fait partie de son entraînement quoi
et jack tu sais qu'il a traversé la
moitié de la ville en courant pour venir
jusqu'ici
tu as mon fric ou quoi non je récupère
juste le truc pour wes wes c'est marrant
ce nom me dit quelque chose je crois que
je connais ce type mais ça fait
longtemps qu'il est pas venu par ici
doit être sacrément remonté contre nous
non c'est pas ça arrête tu crois il est
occupé
il m'a demandé de venir gérer sa place
est aussi j'ai occupé
et j'espère me tromper mais je crois
qu'on sait très bien tous les deux
pourquoi il vient plus jamais ici tu
veux savoir ce qui me met en boule c'est
quand les gens décident à ma place quand
ton frère décide qui va chercher quoi où
et quand par exemple j'en peux plus de
voir ta gueule ici droit je veux plus
voir ta gueule alors tu dis ça à ton
frère
bg way à l'écart soit je ne pas
s'occuper de toi
[Musique]
et jacob's tu cours comme ça depuis les
quais étaient à la même vitesse
ouais et alors ça fait cinq minutes le
1600 mètres c'est ton sac d'école
[Musique]
elie baup lui que je fasse les courses
pour toi il dit qu'il veut te vois tu
sais quoi
vaut mieux qu'ils continuent la ville et
ses poissons et qui la ramène pas trop
est inquiète pas pour moi je suis un
grand garçon un grand garçon ça fait ses
courses tout seul elle continue à parler
comme ça on va voir ce qui va t'arriver
[Musique]
tu as laissé partir le petit jacobs ça
c'était stupide c'est toi qui m'a tout
appris coleman 1
drew lisa vous voulez partager vos
trouvailles avec le reste de la classe
c'est une question piège cx -4 pas x - 6
comme vous l'avez écrit tout juste
burgos d'affirmer un peu toi c'était
quoi ça ça c'était facile c'était facile
ah d'accord faut croire qu'on n'a pas le
même cerveau bref faut que j'aille à
l'entraînement je suis en retard je
t'accompagne tu devrais pas lâcher la
sphère faut que tu tires mais ça
n'arrivera pas je suis plus dans
l'équipe toute façon l'entraîneur veut
plus de moi alors là je comprends pas tu
pourrais avoir une bourse je veux pas
courir pour ce connard tu le connais
bien coleman on habite dans la même rue
je les aime bien parce qu'il n'arrête
pas de prendre la tête à l'entraîneur
lui aussi il est entraîneur il paraît
qu'il est très connu
ah ouais bah
bah quoi bein il est pas comme les
autres lisa j'arrête la course
ok en plus je crois que coleman n'est
plus bon à grand chose
il avait un fils un peu plus vite mois
et un jour il est mort un accident de
voiture
drew tu vas quand même pas abandonner
comme ça c'est parti
wesh wesh
allez viens
bien
quoi bertoua aller
je
[Musique]
en
mon temps
[Musique]
n
ouais quoi ce bordel ça changera jamais
ici où t'as foutu la tondeuse je vais
mal occupé mois écoute je sais que je te
dois de l'argent et je vais te le donner
alors tête on trouve là alors c'est ici
tant petit nid d'amour c'est ici le
tueur est l'une des poules
tu sais que ça me met mal à l'aise ouais
ça me met mal à l'aise et c'est toi qui
met mal à l'aise
assieds toi et ça va dire ça c'est mon
cas le grande roue ce mec là à celles à
venir
lui c'est un bon
écoulent dès cartes de baseball faut
qu'on les change
tu fais la collecte non ouais grave
flash raconta tchèque quand on ferait un
jour au base ball gala il jouait
vraiment bien sérieux vraiment pourrait
talent mais n'a jamais pu passer la
vitesse supérieure un rang - mon fric
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cinq minutes le 1600 mètres vous trouvez
ça bien situe en fait disent oui mais
pour courir tu dois te calmer si tu
gardes pas le contrôle
tu court à l'échec non moi je perds
jamais tu ne fais plus partie de
l'équipe d'athlétisme
on peut dire que tu as perdu mais tu es
rapide à ces prochains championnats de
l'état la kermesse de l'état arrête de
penser à qui tu vas battre
courir c'est pas ça courir c'est courir
c'est tout ah oui ouais il faudrait que
tu lis ton livre alors tu vas me prouver
que j'ai tort vient aux écluses à 5
heures du côté de magnolia
[Musique]
a bordeaux allait pas dans l'eau quoi
enfin dans l'eau sérieux à l'émoi dans
l'eau oui pourquoi il faut que à dans
l'eau super super ok c'est bon ok c'est
bon allez et tu vois les rochers là bas
tu fait l'aller-retour en 15 secondes
s'est tous battu le fessant fois je
lance le chrono go
18 53 comment ça ça compte pas trois
gardes devant toi aller
l'a50
[Musique]
on
me plaît
enfin combien combien j'en ai fait
combien 54 j'en peux plus je pouvais pas
le faire
déjà j arrête je n'en peux plus
[Musique]
vous allez
j'avais raison
mais
mais c'est carrément impossible 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
lève toi faut que tu viennes avec moi à
l'élève toi on y va on y va
seul connard benoît paquette fric alors
tu garde un oeil sur lui
si tu vois un truc tu me le dis
il est où le fric 1 dans le canapé et
ben voila c'était pas c'est dur c'est ça
que cherche un
c'est ça non je crois pas franchement ce
bordel allez si je n'avais pas eu besoin
de toi je t'aurais rien demandé d'accord
regarde regarde ça
[Musique]
j'ai terminé mais j'ai fini à plat tu
sais ce que ça veut dire être à plat
péter pas à plat juste un peu flemmard
quand tu es à plat des muscles ne marche
plus de plus rien rien du tout sauf ton
coeur
mais j'ai jamais vu personne faire plus
de 50 à leur tour dans ce canal pourquoi
vous êtes parti si je te dis que tu peux
pas le faire tu le feras pas courir
c'est pas juste physique c'est dans ta
tête tu t'y connais en bateau
c'est lequel le vôtre on va le voir
et votre jambe
vous savez que la mer et par là tu
parles trop et bohain
ouais pas mal quelques coups de marteau
il m'emmènera en alaska en alaska avec
ce bateau est sur le pont et encore
moins vas-y une touche à rien faut que
j'aille voir quelqu'un au bureau c'est
uma temps 1
à
merci
j'y crois pas le mec me fait courir dans
l'eau après il m'emmène sur son bateau
il me l'a cela à temps il est sénile ton
vieux là je crois que son heure de
gloire est terminée mais c'est la seule
chance qui tu restes dallel
universitaires et les gars vous venez on
faire marc webb à mon avis c'est fini
pour moi avec
ok on y va on voir ici
enfin
tu abandonnes
t'aimes pas trop comme disent que tu
dois faire t'écoutes jamais rien vous
m'avez demandé d'attendre et c'est ce
que j'ai fait il fallait que je voie
site en valait la peine
j'ai ma réponse maintenant
va falloir m'expliquer
la patience
il en faut beaucoup pour être coureur
voulant mener au stade certainement pas
non j'ai mon petit coin à moi
[Musique]
vous faites quoi
j'ai peur de faire quoi ton avis
c'est des chaussures d'entraîneur des
chaussures d'entraîneur
ok
[Musique]
allez
tu vas jusqu'au grand bateau blanc la
fin puis tu tourne à gauche là t'as
droit à une pause d'une minute hockey
après tu as 400 m ensuite tu fait tout
le tour des quais tout le tour vient
voir regardes tu vois le poteau avec un
panneau la torah fait 1600 mètres tout
juste là bas ça marche ça marche
ok le départ c'est la ré hockey
go
j'ai fait qu'elle tend donc pas que ça
je suis en dessous de 50 t'es pas si
rapide
écoute tu as une minute pour récupérer
et on se calme vers et tu viens de faire
un braquage
chaque quart est important trouve son
rythme cardiaque ou 1600 je cours pas le
1600 aussi je cours le 400 m attends je
veux avoir une bourse est allé
l'université alors tu cours sur 1600
csat à distance si tu cours assez vite
qui raoult tu voudras les repart de la
ligne concentre toi sur chaque cas mais
je viens juste de vous dire repart de la
ville
go
[Musique]
67 en moyenne c'est pas trop mal je vais
crever j'ai craqué en est encore loin
il faut que tu le fasses en 58 secondes
chaque 400 mètres 30 58 secondes à l' ag
trop mal j'ai mal partout
c'est ça qui doit aider à tenir
la douleur
il faut que la surface il faut que tu
acceptes et que tu cours avec après tu
vas n'oublie que j'accepte que j'accepte
un jeu à deux doigts de crohn rad fois
devant je te jure
bon dieu
[Musique]
à
charlie st
boudreau il ne voulait pas qu'on
l'emmène à l'hôpital
webb a apparemment tu gères bien la
situation
qu'est-ce que j'étais censé faire je
sais pas appeler les flics
tu viens avec moi
bon alors tu bois tu c'est une longue
histoire
c'est quoi ça c'est une lettre que j'ai
reçue pour mon admission aux cours d'art
de l'université de berkeley
c'est super
félicitations ouais merci
c'est trop cher et mes parents ne
peuvent pas payer si je peux pas avoir
de bourse
ça compte pour rien c'est une fausse
bonne nouvelle mais je peux toujours
devenir artiste de rue si ça marche pas
tu vois moi au moins je vois toi c'est
vrai c'est vrai mais moi je crois que tu
as beaucoup de talent alors tu vas t'en
sortir
sérieusement il s'est passé quoi pour ta
jambe j'ai repris l'entraînement tu as
couru
ouais
c'est coleman mon entraîneur je suis
impressionné monsieur jack obs est dans
ton programme d'entraînement surcharge
et a du temps pour un anniversaire par
exemple ouais chez moi ouais d'accord
c'est vendredi soir vendredi soir quand
sur moi
salut
[Musique]
toi t'es fait pour 1600 pas pour 400
plus tôt tu t'en rendras compte et mieux
ça sera pour toi je cours le 400 m
[Musique]
gros débat brad pitt a bien fait devant
la grotte
il ya tout bah ouais y'a tout c'est la
dernière fois je te le promets d'accord
je vais faire une petite chanson pour
ton départ ça fait comme ça et un et
deux et un deux trois s'appelle trou et
là un truc à faire
tu es encore postés sur cuba si si toi
tu lemoine clap
c'est bon il ya tout ouais et qu'elle
veut alors accompagne le petit pour
cette semaine
flash c'est bon pour cette semaine
j'étais si j'étais ton frère jamais je
t'enverrai voir un mec comme moi tu peux
pas comprendre et vient voir
on vient voir ça c'est pour toi regarde
ouais c'est pour toi tu crois quoi que
c'était fini un thème est terminée c'est
ça que tu croyais non ça marche pas
comme ça tu bosses avec nos toits mois
ios peuvent tous ensemble
tu mets une clope black feelings club
c'est bon pour tes poumons
[Musique]
il est pas là alors vous pouvez faire
demi-tour et rentrer chez vous trois que
meubles tu fais du business on le sait
bien ce qui se passe ici je sais qui tu
es et couture
l'est on ferait en dehors de ça
tu fais pitié
il a dit quoi
mais d'accord
ouais on est d'accord
si je gagne pas je passe au 1600
j'arrête le 400 m ouais
comptez sur moi pour gagner
a repris du service regarder apprendre à
les messieurs c'est parti on a invité
pour le 400 mètres aujourd'hui
vous n'avez pas oublier monsieur tir
comme coureur à vos marques
prêts
pareil
[Musique]
non
récit
vas-y
[Musique]
vas-y whitehall
voilà
et voilà
[Musique]
il
à mille temps entre en mauvais
[Musique]
tu peux pas battre whitehall sur 400 m
mais si tu travailles dur tu sera bon
sur 1600
salut c'est parti
ça va passer une bonne soirée
et être cool que tu sois vie
[Musique]
un trou
tu es venu bec et c'est là que tu fous
tout seul à voir ça va les gars ouais et
toi tu fais là sociale les courses mais
qu un ses choix pour toi
et détends-toi détends toi mec détends
toi c'est une fête gros il faut que tu
bois
bien calé sa poule bien d'accord avec
toi gaffe à lui on s'en tape
je peux très emprunté pour une seconde
est doux et là quand tu bien aller
elisa je peux te parler de ministres et
sur s'inquiète pas pour elle a des
grands salut ça va
eric lâche moi car toi d'là mais qu'est
ce qui t'arrive toit a déjà arrêté
arrête arrête ton trop gros noms
que pas rentrer
il est parti il avait beaucoup bu c'est
tout non mais il reste de lui chercher
des excuses ils étaient en train de
tripoter tu allais te laisser faire ou
quoi en fait j'étais sur le point de le
remettre à sa place moi même ah ouais
t'es une dure toi c'est ça attends tu me
crois pas genre j'aurais pu griffé jeu
c'est pas rien j'avais très bien plus de
faire cet oeil au beurre noir
c'est comme un bouche en fait c'est
mignon
faut que j'y aille j'ai entraînement
amateurs
faut que j'y retourne de toute façon
bonne nuit
coleman vous êtes là
vous avez oublié l'entraînement c'est un
genre de test encore c'est une belle
collection vous les écoutez encore
c'est votre fils
vous étiez aussi dur avec lui qu'avec
moi il devait vous détestez t'as pas le
droit de parler de mon flic c'est mon
fils
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu t'es fait à l'oeil je
tombais
de tomber ouais ouais
[Musique]
tu es tombé ouais
j'espère qu'elle en valait la peine
[Musique]
alors tu es encore là
faut faire quel temps pour avoir une
bourse à berkeley n'a aucune chance
t'écoutes rien vu le temps qui m'a fallu
pour que tu te mettes aux 1600 mètres
mais si je fais moins de quatre minutes
je ferai ce que vous voudrez
ne cuisine plus jamais tu as un truc tu
as
dans un truc en toi profonde et moi
enfouis il faut que tu te battes
que tu affrontes cette peur il le faut
si tu le fais pas tu deviendras comme
moi
et je crois pas que j'en ai envie
mais si tu me fais
peu importe si tu ne remet jamais les
pieds sur une piste parce que si tu
affrontes vraiment cette peur ça
changera d'avis je te promets ya rien
dans la vie qui soit aussi dur à faire
mais tu dois le faire oh oui tu dois le
fait après ça la douleur se mettra plus
jamais sur ton chemin
tu en seras sortie et quand il sera sur
le point de s'évanouir
quand les gens bougent plus que plus
respirer qu'on voit plus rien tu sauras
que ça ne fait que commencer
et ces inquié beau ce mot
c'est ça que j'essaye de l'enseigné
ok
ok ok tu veux commencer quand
tu va transporter ce pneu sous l'eau tu
dois faire 20 lire tous
[Musique]
c'est un élu d'une prochaine pu faire
d'une seule voix
il
[Musique]
bien tu as fait 63 pas mal
ben ammar ces quatre secondes de moins
qu'au début
[Musique]
nous
impressionnant désolé de vous dire ça
comme ça mais ce bateau n'ira jamais en
a partout croissance tu sais quoi
ferme là elle termine ça qu'est ce que
t'en dis pourquoi il y a que moi qui
travaille mais dans un sens et dans
l'autre
mon pote le bon rappelez moi pourquoi je
peux pas avoir un steak on travaille pas
tes muscles aujourd'hui aller prendre un
beau merci j'en voulais pas
j'ai pris fin vous désirez qu'on sait
pas autre chose vous ne pourriez lui
remettre un peu plus de battre s'il vous
plaît allez mange
du moins comment ça se passe avec cette
fille c'est juste une amie
quoi quel con quoi non pas par goût ou
quoi c'est vous qu'on n'avait pas
tusa perdre
[Musique]
et bien matinal dit moi je sais
tu vas courir du court vite en fait
combien
[Musique]
je savais pas que tu jouais je connais
une chanson que tu veux que je te la
chante avec plaisir ça ça parle pas de
toi
ca c
hamas et maxwell
[Musique]
oui
non c'est une chouette
aristote 1,5
mick jagger et michael jackson
[Musique]
e
où
mon
oh
vous
[Musique]
c'est le meilleur coureur de l'état son
entraîneur dé qui fera moins de quatre
minutes cette année il doit courir
contre lui oui si tu ne bat pas aux
régionales dirai jamais au championnat
d'état je suis vraiment très content que
vous soyez venu je sais que vous passe
énormément de temps avec trou pourquoi
est ce que vous faites ça parce qu'il
court vite parce qu'il court vite oui
c'est un garçon très gentil avant
j'étais photographe et j'adorerais le
faire poser il fallait qu'il reste à 6
pommes des heures non je vous assure
c'est un super modèle mais ça l'énervait
beaucoup vous pouvez pas imaginer à
quelle maman
j'avais 6 ans tu étais vraiment
merveilleux se garder de très bons prix
oui et sur la photo du bas c'est qui
c'est moi oui quand tu étais pas
d'honneur de sheila était tellement
mignon sur ces photos bonjour s'allume
en java qu'est ce qu'il fait là lui
qu'est ce qu'il fait là
oui ce qu'est ce qu'il fout là non reste
à ta place le vieux aux victimes mais
qu'est ce que tu fais non non non non
non
alors il ya quoi pour dr james je suis
vraiment désolé je ne sais pas quoi
faire
moi aussi je suis désolé je je veux pas
que drew finisse comme son frère mais
s'il s'entraîner et si il reste
concentré et il pourra s'en sortir
seul franck dally il faut que tu ailles
le voir ce soir
vas-y toi même demain j'ai une compet
bonne chance mais tu vas quand même y
aller tout de suite aller au bout vas-y
et l'on manque pas vrai
ouais
y'a pas tout
y a que la moitié
si tu étais moi
dis moi ce que tu ferais ma place tu
ferais quoi
quoi
[Musique]
tire toi mais j'en ai pas fini avec toi
et avec ton frère non plus
[Musique]
gagnant de cette course participera au
championnat d'état
tu lâche rien
quoi qu'il arrive
tu mets tout dans la course
c'est maintenant que ça se passe
tu laisses tout sur la piste
horreur
à vos marques
c'est un départ en douceur la tête
lâche pas le rythme
jack of suis 5e ce de très près
elles aideront vas-y
[Musique]
si un bon
m
[Musique]
croix dessus
ils s'inquiètent toujours des haches pas
green
la chevalerie
allen
[Musique]
jacob super tu peux poursuivre dans les
index domine clairement
cinquièmes jeux remportent cette épreuve
3 avec tryo
sera d'or une charge s'inquiète riz qui
participera au championnat d'étape
man a lâché tu as décroché en plein
milieu non j'ai donné tout ce que
j'avais un talent h et a abandonné j'ai
vu écoute je sais pas si tu aurais pu le
battre ce gars mais c'est parce que je
t'ai demandé de faire ce que je t'ai
demandé de faire ça dit m tout ce que tu
as un jour tu te souviendras ce moment
et tu te détestera n'avoir pas essayé de
pousser plus loin n'avoir pas pu saisir
cette opportunité incroyable maintenant
t'as plus rien et tu ne m'a même pas
donné de raisons de continuer n'ira pas
au championnat d'état c'est fini vous
voulez plus m'entraîner je me demande
pourquoi je vous ai écoutés coleman
regardez vous dans un miroir
vous n'avez rien vous n'avez même pas de
famille
retournez dans votre trou à rats et
continuez à vous saouler la gueule
jusqu'à en crever
comme on a pu m'envoyer shelly
comment tu as pu le faire un truc pareil
il va débarquer chez nous tu le sais ça
je t'ai déjà dit de pas t'inquiéter pour
elle il aime bien faire des menaces
il aurait pu mais gorgée d'eau laissent
pas impressionner et drôle quand est ce
que tu vas arrêter de te mentir à temps
c'est toi qui me disent ah là tu ferais
bien de te regarder parce que le vieux à
côté ce n'est pas notre père trop
[Musique]
j'ai perdu la course si ça t'intéresse
où
tu es fâché à cause de la course ça va
ouais je sais que ça va j'ai juste
besoin de rester un peu seul c'est tout
les mauvais jours je sais ce que c'est
mais si un autre problème tu sais on
peut en parler ensemble
ah ouais ok mais tu veux que je te dise
quoi tu peux pas comprendre ce que je
suis en train de vivre
tu sais pas tout ce que j'ai dû
traverser alors retourne intègre les
mouillages et à ta petite vie parfaite
j'ai pas besoin de ton aide et je veux
pas tu as pitié non plus en fait c'est
ce que je croyais aussi
[Musique]
drôle lève toi on doit partir drew on
doit partir
non je viens pas avec toi hawass à dreux
1 ne m'énerve pas ok pas marco tu vas
faire quoi
les toits [ __ ] mais laisse moi
tranquille quatre vaches mangent pas
d'ici
il faut que t'arrêtes arriver mais
arrête un peu plus ou moins graves
la semoy [ __ ]
j'étais désolé tu aurais dû faire croire
d'accord s'est amusé m
tu as un truc en toi profonde et moi aux
fruits
il faut que tu te battes
que tu affrontes cette peur
il le faut
si tu le fais pas
tu deviendras comme moi
et si tu fais ça changera d'avis
la douleur se mettra plus jamais sur ton
chemin tu en seras sortie
et quand il sera sur le point de
s'évanouir quand les gens bougent plus
tu peux plus respirer croit plus rien
qui saura que ça ne fait que commencer
[Musique]
oh
je les fais j'ai couru ce rail jpeg
et j'ai fait face
j'ai fait face puis je suis passé à
travers c'était tellement beau
vous aviez raison voilà c'est très bien
es tu l'as fait tout seul et ça ne fait
que commencer
[Musique]
m
vous voulez bien m'aider
je veux toujours faire moins de quatre
minutes
ah t'as pas besoin de moi mais j'ai
besoin de votre aide
[Musique]
ça c'est vrai d'accord
c'est fini pour toi la voiture mon petit
gant
[Musique]
coleman du football coéquipières c'est
vrai ça petit coup de main ça fait pas
la personne
[Musique]
écoute pour l'autre jour
là
papeete
un peu d'eau
un peu
désolé j'ai pas fait exprès je suis
vraiment désolé
[Musique]
ouais wesley
ouais ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et puis la volée quelle est la raison de
votre appel je me suis trompé en
traitant comme un frangin wes reste à
l'intérieur ou est ce qu'est ce que tu
fous là qu'est ce que je fous là à ton
avis hein ah oui tu aimes ça cognait
comme au baseball
passez moi mais c'est qui qui paye le
loyer c'est toi hein
tout ce que tu as tu le dois tu as
compris hein
mais flash qui c'est qui paye le loyer
ici un centre intérieur je pourrais
peut-être lui mettre une balle en argent
trop qu'est ce que je vais faire rentrer
à l'intérieur kamal kamal élus coleman
colmar ça va ça va j'suis là où s
appelle les secours s'te plaît prétend
vous soigner vous cédiez au sort mais
voilà s'il te plaît appel de l'être s'il
te plaît mais milite à l'école mal comme
bonne ou son malaise
pitié laissez pas aller regarder moi
ouais
[Rires]
[Musique]
où
nous
[Musique]
et
en
tu sais ce que je fais mieux que les
autres
[Musique]
rien
mais alors vraiment rien
je veux pas que tu reviennes ici
[Musique]
tu ne dois pas caché ce que tu as
chiche
[Musique]
est-ce que ça va
oui ça va
persée
d'être venu
alors qu'il y à championnat je préfère
être ici
t'en fais pas pour ça mais j'aurais bien
aimé que tu y ailles je sais que tu
aurais pu battre saint james
c'est pas ça le problème
je m'en fiche de gagner
je m'en fiche de saint james
il ya un truc que je dois faire
[Musique]
les regards
mais
[Musique]
c'est pas facile de remplacer coleman
mais vu qu'il peut pas être là ça compte
autant qu'à championnat d'état pour moi
[Musique]
comment tu as deviné
je savais que tu ferais ça pour lui
bon ça
[Musique]
ça va aller
je
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
3 2
go
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en vingt ans
des fois les matins nous a trop volés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
combien trois minutes 57
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue aux championnats d'athlétisme
universitaire de l'état de californie
dans le com et couloirs nous avons mike
smith pour lui
deuxième couloir charles st james pour
l'université de los angeles troisième
pouvoir
jacobs pour l'université de berkeley
quatrième fois
bat zhang pour l'université de
californie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce